[Música]
bueno les contaba que venía esta tarde a
contarles tres cosas que me
atraen mucho que me apasionan como son
la enseñanza el aprendizaje y también
cómo aprenden las
organizaciones
y les contaba un poco los momentos en
los que somos papás
intensos llenos de aprendizaje que
estamos teniendo en estos últimos años
especialmente estos dos años uno de
ellos es cuando cuando tenemos que
ayudar a nuestros hijos que estudian
primaria que pues resulta todo bastante
complicado tenemos que refrescar no nos
acordamos de nada y tenemos que estar
ahí a la talla un poco no como padres
y bueno como dicen nuestros abuelos pues
todo sea todo sea por nuestros hijos hay
que esforzarse y dar y dar todo
y lo que contaba es que cuando realmente
empezamos la jornada o antes de empezar
vamos la jornada diciendo pues
tecnología odio los móviles no
me sale nada nada bien se ha actualizado
el móvil este tipo de cosas que de todos
los que luchamos el día a día con la
tecnología
pero llega un momento que llega el
convite y nos mandan todos para casa y
de pronto todos pasamos a hacerte la
baja de trabajadores y se crea una nueva
situación
y esa situación consiste en qué
en que tenemos que aprender cada día más
y más en el 2020 podemos decir que es un
punto clave dentro de la historia en el
que el aprendizaje forma uno
[Música]
bueno
y el aprendizaje en el lugar de trabajo
toma un punto importante y más que más
que nunca
el aprendizaje resulta muy importante no
aquí lo resumo que el 2020 ha sido un
punto clave en nuestra historia más
reciente y el aprendizaje en el trabajo
es y será más importante que nunca
pasemos a la siguiente bueno y es que
las empresas en estos momentos en estos
dos últimos años están viviendo una
carrera de fondo para hacer frente a
esta situación caótica e inquietante
y está claro no que poco a poco vamos
caminando
hacia hacia el trabajo remoto no a
trabajar desde casa o al menos trabajar
en un formato
mixon vamos un poquito más palante
en este en este corto pero intenso
periodo de tiempo el aprender para
adaptarnos y hacer frente a esta nueva
situación se ha convertido una valiosa
herramienta para enfrentarnos a este
cambio en el que vivimos y podemos decir
ya no
y vale
no se queda una anécdota vale y es que
en ningún momento de la historia el
aprendizaje corporativo y es importante
decir el aprendizaje corporativo el
aprendizaje de las sociedades ha sido
una pieza clave para poder subsistir
no no hay forma
cambia tu vale y es que
la cob y nos deja algunas cosas algunas
consecuencias no solo negativas sino
algunas consecuencias positivas como
pueden ser
un nuevo paradigma en las relaciones en
cómo nos relacionamos con nuestros
compañeros cómo nos relacionamos
con cola dentro de la empresa
personas y equipos describen que
descubren que necesitan adquirir nuevas
habilidades para desarrollar sus
trabajos y nace una oportunidad para
pensar las organizaciones como aprende
las personas como aprenden los equipos y
cómo aprende de las organizaciones esto
hace que el aprendizaje y el desarrollo
de personas sea más desafiante que nunca
y les traigo ahora unas cifras
importantes y fíjense la primera de
ellas la más importante que nueve de
cada diez directivos de recursos humanos
10 personas que se dedican a la gestión
de personas piensan que los trabajadores
o las personas que están ahora mismo en
sus empresas
tienen carencias o van a tener carencias
formativas en los próximos años no deja
ser
mucho más significativo no es igual al
anterior
que el 50 por ciento de las personas que
ahora mismo están trabajando tienen un
set de herramientas
insuficiente para desarrollar supuesto
trabajo esto significa que el 50 por
ciento de la mitad de las personas que
estamos en esta sala nos falta algo para
poder desarrollar con éxito nuestra
actividad laboral y esto lo que hace es
que tengamos una baja motivación poco
entusiasmo frustración y pensar sobre
todo pues que no algo
y esto lo que está generando es que el
29 por ciento de las personas que
estaban en las empresas que están las
corporaciones tienen mucho menos
compromiso tiene menos compromiso que
antes del cobi
a esto hay que añadirle que el 40 el 14
por ciento de los puestos van a ser
automatizados van a ser robotizados van
a estar puestos o gestionados por la
tecnología y que el 13 por ciento de las
personas que ahora mismo están
trabajando no son eficientes en su
puestos laborales
pero
no no hay que asustarse no hay que
asustarse un poco en estas cifras con
esta data de recursos humanos y hay que
mirarlo de una forma más amplia porque
desaparecen profesiones pero aparecen
nuevas nuevos perfiles el mercado
demanda nuevos profesionales como ahí he
puesto director de felicidad visual
thinker community manager puestos que
nos suenan raro pero que muy pronto
estaremos acostumbrados y no serán muy
familiares
y qué hacen las organizaciones que
podemos hacer las empresas que pueden
hacer las empresas para resolver este
problema de talento que tienen y
básicamente tres acciones acciones de
skilling acciones de skilling y acciones
de skilling y que significa skilling
bueno pues cuando hablo de skilling lo
que lo que tratamos o las empresas lo
que deben de tratar es promover dentro
de las organizaciones el aprendizaje y
para eso que hay que hacer bueno pues
hay que todos los que trabajamos tenemos
que cambiar nuestro main set y tenemos
que ir hacia un aprendizaje continuo y
constante o sea nos sirve que aprendamos
en un momento puntual tenemos que ir
aprendiendo todos los días y de forma
constante todos los días es motivo de
aprendizaje y cuando hablo de esto no
estoy hablando de universidades
corporativas como puede ser de
university u otras tantas universidades
importantes estoy hablando de una
formación bajo demanda ya no nos sirve
que nos manden un listado de cursos a
principio de año en el que yo me
inscribo uno de ellos tenemos que ir a
una formación
especializada
cumpla las necesidades de los equipos
las necesidades de las empresas que
vayan encaminado hacia los objetivos de
las empresas los o caer
en los cupcakes y demás índices para
conseguir objetivos dentro de la empresa
y para eso una herramienta que tenemos
es poner a disposición de nuestros
equipos de nuestras personas
repositorios que no deja de ser buscar
un lugar dentro de la oficina o dentro
de la empresa donde haya una estantería
con material de consulta que haya
revistas técnicas que hayan libros que
haya papers que da documentos que todos
podamos compartir o simplemente una
carpeta en el drive donde haya cosas a
disposición de toda la empresa
yo hace años trabajaba en una gran
empresa petrolera y una acción que se
hizo una acción formativa y se dio un
libro solamente al equipo directivo y
solo se dio se compraron 10 ejemplares
para los miembros de esa empresa esto
hoy es
impensable no si se piensa que un
material es bueno ese material es bueno
para todas las empresas personas que
trabajan dentro de la empresa por ahí
están los repositorios y sobre todo otra
cosa muy importante es crear grupos
crear grupos para compartir estos
aprendizajes y para compartir esa estas
experiencias
en acciones como desayunos de trabajo en
el que podemos trabajar entre podemos
desayunar o tomarnos un café de
distintos miembros
de la empresa o pizzas de trabajo donde
un día a la semana pues comemos se puede
hacer presencial como a distancia open
space y sobre todo algo que me gusta
mucho y que disfrutó mucho participando
de ellos que son los grupos de prácticas
las cop donde personas de la misma
empresa o diferentes empresas comparte
sus experiencias y practican cosas que
luego llevarán a sus puestos no es una
forma de ir probando cosas para luego
incorporar a nuestro día a día del
trabajo otra de las herramientas que
tienen las empresas son s las killing o
actualizar el conocimiento vamos un paso
más antes teníamos que aprender
para pensar lo que iba a pasar en el
futuro aquí ya hay problemas y estamos
hablando con estas acciones de ese 50
por ciento de las empresas que tienen
dificultades para para desarrollar su
actividad
los departamentos de recursos humanos
hacen detectan estas necesidades y
piensan y hacen lo que hacen es
actualizar el conocimiento de todas o de
parte de la compañía y esto qué consiste
pues primero en ofrecer especialización
nos sirve una formación generalista si
no hay que ir resolviendo problemas pero
el problema de persona por persona
departamento por departamento
que la gente o que nosotros como
colaboradores veamos que siempre hay
conocimiento nuevo que siempre tenemos
que ir aprendiendo cosas nuevas que
siempre tenemos que ir actualizando
y que estos aprendizajes sean cortos y
precisos no ya no no podemos ir a
formaciones muy largas de semanas
tenemos que ir aprendizajes costos de un
día 23 a lo sumo que sean cortos
precisos y que siempre nos lleven a la
práctica y la reflexión y sobre todo
formarnos y desarrollar la sof skill a
todas las habilidades blancas como son
la empatía la comunicación no violenta o
la gestión del tiempo y por ultimo
la última de las herramientas o la
última problema que podemos encontrar
o puede detectar el departamento de
personas es re skilling la empresa
piensa
o es consciente de que no tiene talento
para hacer frente al mercado para hacer
frente a lo que pasa en el exterior y es
momento como de reinventarnos de
inventar personas reinventar equipos y
reinventar la empresa entonces en esta
fase las empresas que se encuentran en
esta fase o los equipos que se
encuentran en esta fase o las personas
que se encuentran en esta fase tiene que
aprender a trabajar con equipos diversos
esto quiere decir que no tenemos que
aprender que tenemos que abandonar la
idea de trabajar los abogados con los
abogados los ingenieros con los
ingenieros
y así sucesivamente sino que tenemos que
aprender a convivir con distintas
personas de distintos perfiles y
distintos roles empresariales
tenemos también que aprender a ver qué
hacen otros departamentos porque el
departamento de finanzas se lleva tan
bien unos con otros y porque el
departamento de marketing no se hablan
unos con otros hay que analizar estas
pequeñas cosas y tenemos que aprender de
lo que hace bien nuestro compañero y por
último tenemos que tener en este punto
una visión sistémica tenemos que ver que
todas las piezas de la empresa son
importantes y que si se para una de
estas piezas repercute en toda la
empresa y si va a una rápido más rápidas
todas y si se frena una de estas ruedas
dentadas se para toda la empresa
podemos decir bueno esto está muy bien
en mi empresa no va a hacer nada de esto
está muy bien la teoría pero qué puedo
hacer yo a nivel personal yo como como
cómo puedo aportar o como yo puedo
prever este este caos organizativo y lo
primero que podemos hacer
es
utilizar esta página web wheel robot
take my job y esto lo que nos va a decir
es cómo está nuestra profesión por
dentro
aquí hay varias cifras pero hay tres
como muy importantes la primera que ella
es el riesgo de automatización o sea
esto es
qué posibilidades hay de que mi trabajo
la actividad que yo desempeño
desaparezca por ejemplo esto es una
buena profesión el riesgo de que ese
auto matices de un 5 por ciento hay
profesiones que van a desaparecer
y aquí es un 90 por ciento es un 80 por
ciento entonces si veo que mi profesión
tiene una automatización alta significa
que estoy
en peligro de extinción otro valor
importante es el porcentaje de
crecimiento aquí hay 18 con 9 o sea este
sector que yo he puesto aquí está
creciendo a un 9 por ciento hay sectores
que están en decreciendo entonces si
estoy trabajando en un sector una
empresa que esta cifra está bajando está
bajando esto significa que pronto no
existirá vale como pasó no hace mucho
tiempo que íbamos a los sitios que no
reparaban el paraguas y ahora es
imposible que nos reparen un paraguas
porque ya no existe ese profesión
entonces esto lo tenemos ahí en esa
variable y también un dato muy chulo y
muy importante ahí donde pone wells es
cuánto se paga la hora de este
profesional entonces si tenemos que ver
si estamos en un perfil estamos haciendo
un rol que se remunera bien o se
remunere mal vale eso lo tienen todos en
la página
en esa página web y es que nuestra
formación no deja de ser como si fuera
un helado no van a permitir que haga
esta comparación
este es un helado normal es un helado
que puede gustar los más puede gustarnos
- algunos niños no lo aceptarían si les
están compran este helado es un helado
que cuesta 50 céntimos se puede tomar en
muchos restaurantes de comida rápida
pero en cambio te podemos también optar
a este tipo de helado probablemente el
helado incluso a lo mejor es peor que el
anterior pero a este lado se le ha
añadido un envoltorio diferente el
envase es mucho más atractivo se le ha
añadido un sirope hay frutas hay
galletas está todo estudiado todo es
armónico y esto pasa con las personas
las personas tenemos que ver en qué
punto está nuestra profesión hay que ver
en qué punto está nuestro trabajo y
sobre esto tenemos que empezar a
añadirle tópix para que sea más
atractivo y esto lo que hacemos es que
un helado que vale 50 céntimos pase a
pasar siete euros
lo pasamos bueno y aquí ya resumo
estas cualidades que tenemos que tener
para estar al día para encontrar el
trabajo en concreto son doce las tres
primeras más o menos ya las he comentado
ser proactivos o sea no dejarnos
quedarnos con los brazos con los brazos
cruzados ver qué está pasando nuestra
profesión que no me pille el toro
y ser muy críticos con lo que yo hago
vale porque hay que estar preparados
para lo que pase que no pase cómo va a
pasar con algunas personas en la banca
que se han dicho que se van a despedir
mucha gente que se va después mucha
gente tenemos que ser proactivos prever
críticos ver qué cosas me faltan ver esa
mirada y ver qué está pasando en el
exterior para hacer frente a este
momento
hay que hacer las cosas de forma
diferente tenemos poco a poco ir
haciendo cambios dentro de nuestra
empresa hay que aprovechar las
formaciones que se nos dan la empresa no
hay de una forma pasiva
hay que aprender destrezas los costes
osea eso significa
desde estas cruzadas nos vale con ser el
mejor mecánico tengo que saber un poco
de ventas tengo que saber un poco de
comunicación tenemos que tener un claro
control de las habilidades blancas
siempre actualizar nuestros
conocimientos
aprender qué hacen otros ver cómo hacen
la competencia ver cómo hacen mis
compañeros es su trabajo data del driver
medir medir todo lo que hago todo lo que
no se puede medir es no se puede mejorar
lo que estoy haciendo está produciendo
más bienestar está produciendo
beneficios que la tecnología nos domine
no nosotros domina la tecnología y le
aprenden y quiero quiero cerrar con esta
frase de tólhuin dolph el autor de este
libro la tercera hora que dice los
analfabetos del siglo 21 no serán
aquellos que no sepan leer y escribir
sino aquellos que no sepan aprender
desaprender y re aprender muchas gracias
[Aplausos]